our next topic are convolutional
networks these are very popular models
for image processing because they uh
they capture local features quite well
um and we're going to use some data from
the C4 100 data set this is one of these
uh big data sets that are curated by the
the Deep Learning Community to sort of
compare different models and the 100
stands for 100 data classes it's 100
class classification problem yes so for
reference a random guessing here should
be about 1% accurate so okay so um so
this the pattern is going to be similar
to the hitters in M's data we will sort
of specify the data sets and then we'll
specify the uh the the mod the network
that is how features are transformed to
scores Define the loss to find the
fitter and then look at the results okay
for the cffr data comes packaged uh in
the torch Vision package which is
convenient to in order for us to fit it
we're going to actually do a little bit
of pre-processing uh this is done here
all that's going on here is it's
rescaled to to be floating point from 0
to one instead of integer 0 to 255 and
just reorders the the arrays so does a
little
transpose okay so then we we have our
data module like we did for the other
examples we have test training data test
data and we'll use 20% of training data
as validation and each batch will be of
size
128 so the these input images it's three
dimens I tensor right that's right three
color channels yes yes so images color
images are represented as RGB so there
it's U I
think Trevor is talking about this three
here in look when we look at the
different data set so the um the images
are have three channels uh and are 32x
32 this these are RGB channels there's
also RGB Alpha perhaps and the the mnus
data actually this was a one here but um
so we're showing you what a typical
batch looks like cuz we've got batch
size of 128 here that's right so there's
128 images randomly selected for a batch
and and then those are the dimensions 3
32 32 yes yeah this is just a sort of
Sanity check to see that the we've made
the data loader that we understand what
the data is looking like when it before
it goes in let's just take a look at you
know these images to see uh the
resolution is not uh is not great it's
32x 30 to but they're still recognizable
objects right this one is a wolf this
one might be Bigfoot I don't know
but uh this is an apple that's a nice
thing about having images as as data
observations because you can look at
them usually you can't look at high
dimensional data so nicely but images
you can
yes okay
um so now we're going to Define our
neural network and what we're going to
do is as is common in these in these
tasks is we'll we'll sort of make a sort
of multiscale kind of version of the
analysis that is we're going to do a
convolutional filter that's this Con 2D
from the um the NN module and apply the
ru and then Max do what's called a Max
pool over the output and we're going to
do this at several different scale so
the way we're going to do this is to
define a basic layer that we'll call
building block and we'll use building
blocks of different sizes in this
multiscale kind of
repres network you by the way you should
have read the chapter on convolutional
neural networks um before doing this lab
because it'll be much more
understandable and then you'll
understand the idea of doing convolution
and pooling in in in that order sequence
of those operations yes yes this is of
course just the lab um and so what we're
doing here is effectively um making a
new type typ of layer so we've already
seen some of the some of the layers that
are in this NN package we've seen like
nn. sequential nn. linear nn. relu these
are all the kind of operations that can
be done by one of the nodes and here
nn.com 2D is one of those so what we're
doing here is essentially making our own
layer that we're going to later use to
build in our in our CFR 100 Network each
layer each of these convolution and Max
pool layers
okay so what we're going to do is um
we're going to make a sequence as I said
we're going to use our building block um
and apply this convolution and Max pool
on different scales and the scales are
going to go as follows these numbers
here are the channels that are going to
be um applied for uh for each out the
output of each of the um each of the the
building block layers so input and
output I should say the first one is has
three channels and we're going to Output
um uh 32 channels and if you uh one of
the things about the max pooling since
we did it a kernel size of 2x two it
will half the size of the image each
time so we start off with um 3x 32x 32
and then we'll finish with 32x 16x 16
and then we'll have 32x 16x 16 and 64x
8X 8 Etc so once we have this object
that can do this convolution and Max
pool that's what we called building
block before we're just going to apply
these in sequence so we have these
different sizes this defines the sort of
scales that we'll look at and we'll just
make a layer sequential layer that uses
these in in a sequence and here we're
using the list comprehension of python
we have seen that in the labs before if
not on video then in the text of the
labs and and this argument here star
that just takes a sequence and gives all
of those as arguments to sequential so
this is really nice Jonathan in the in
the previous one with the m list we did
layer one layer two but here you can
just programmatically specify the thing
and just go in a loop and set up all
these layers yes it's much more compact
we would have had to have each one might
take four or five lines so it would have
been 20 lines instead of well six or
seven and then at the end we'll have 256
channels and we're going to have to
ultimately output that to 100
um uh 256 channels and it's going to be
a 2X two image so at the the final the
final output after the max pool will be
256 x 2x two we'll output that to 512
and then do a re value for good measure
and output to 100 that's the number of
classes and okay once we specified our
Network in that fashion uh the training
Etc will be will be similar um in this
case uh we can the summary is a little
long and but it should be predictable in
how to read it now there quite a few
parameters now almost almost a million
parameters yeah
yeah um so we won't dwell on it but
we've used a sort of default Training
Method for all of the all the sastic
gradients operations so far um torch has
several other variants of stochastic
gradients so we're going to use one of
those here but um it doesn't well that
just that that uh where is the where
does the optimizer that comes into this
uh when we tell it's a classification
problem we give this these extra this
special Optimizer but it's let's not
Dell on that okay so we'll fit it as we
have done all the other ones and let's
take a look at how it's done well this
one takes a little bit longer um
depending on your Hardware um it can be
this here says it took 10 minutes or so
on a pretty modern Mac uh laptop with an
M1 chip but that's not too bad we only
gave it 30 um EPO and you'd probably
give it more yeah yeah uh especially if
the accuracy is still improving let's
take a look
um looks like the validation accuracy is
a bit leveling out so maybe 30 EPO won't
won't be won't help much I mean anything
more probably won't help much yeah
training of course will get better and
better okay and so sto 40% accuracy on
the 100 class classification problems
pretty good yes compared to the Baseline
of 1% yes
yeah uh and I I think we I think the
what's the current State ofthe art in
the 70s for this data set perhaps I
think so yeah so people tweak and and
tune these models forever and increase
their accuracy yes eventually they'll be
the field will overfit the data even if
any different method won't okay um so
the accuracy on test data is about
41%
okay
there are a few other topics uh on
convolution NW works if you have um
certain Hardware there are accelerations
you can try um and finally one one nice
thing about uh these models is that you
don't have to just use your own computer
sometimes to to to use them you can
sometimes use the work that someone else
has done so you can use pre-trained
models and uh the torch um torch data
sets include these model models called
reset of various sizes reset 50 I think
corresponds to 50 sort of Max pool I
think that the 50 is how many how many
yes convolution Max pooling laders and
this was trained on a thousand class
image classification problem yes so you
can uh Now app pass in your own images
and and look at the the different
classes so we have an example here about
how to do that that we uh encourage you
to do offline and these are shown these
are shown in the book we we show some
photographs
from a photograph album and and actually
classify them and and we we show the
code for doing that yeah
yes